the dr shark varshavsky is back in the
building are you ready
hello sharks hello i'm bobby edwards
hello bobby this is my mother judy hello
judy and we're here seeking 350 000 for
a 5 share
wow that means they're worth quite a bit
of money simply put we're in the
business to help you do your business
now there's something that each and
every one of you are doing wrong every
day of your lives and it's adversely
affecting your health the reality is
living life is adverse to your health
everything you do in a given day just by
living adversely affects the length of
your life that doesn't mean we should
stop living our lives though wouldn't
you agree
oh that business the american toilet is
this that thing that you put a stool
under and it raises the angle okay we
have a muscle called the pubertalis
muscle that wraps around the base of our
colon forming a kink and only when we
are in a squat position does this muscle
completely relax the one thing i gotta
interrupt them right away is okay pitch
the product but pitching the product as
saying this can eliminate all the
problems that the united states
population has with their gi tract come
on now first of all not even everybody
struggles with constipation and the big
reason why we do struggle with
constipation is because of our diets not
because of our posture on the toilet
we've come up with a perfect solution
squatty potty a simple stool that's been
carefully designed that allows the user
to
squat
in a healthy position essentially a very
inexpensive piece of plastic that could
essentially be anything to lift up your
legs and when not in use it stores
neatly away neatly away as he shoves it
back one inch squatty potty will be the
goose that lays the golden egg for you
guys and us too now who wants to climb
on board and help us get america bobby
how do you squeeze out a profit he hit
him with a dad joke right away he saw
the healthy colon and he wanted to
squeeze out a profit it takes an
advanced sense of humor i don't expect
everybody to understand how do you sell
them to who they're all available online
you know we have no retail and amazon
we're not in retail yet holy crap you're
so holy crap right there's a crapload of
money in squad no seriously you're
selling 2.7 million online i think i
know why why
weren't you just on dr oz oh no
it's going dark it's going brown it's
getting flushed in 2012 we were on dr oz
yes that's how we got that 1 million
dollars right and you know what doctors
us said about it it works that's the
first time we've heard that why can't
somebody just get a stack of books and
lift their legs
well said fellow shark squatty potty is
designed specifically for the task it's
perfectly angled well it can't be
perfectly angled because you don't know
the height of the individual using the
the toilet pam and i are gonna need
different squatty potty heights i think
it's very very difficult to get people
to change their minds about things we're
used to going to the toilet a certain
way there's actually some evidence
behind squatting so i can't knock this
product but i can say that we just need
to be careful with the marketing of like
the healthy happy colon
because people who have serious colon
issues will think this will be the
solution and ignore legitimate treatment
like you have no idea how many of my
patients who have legitimate symptoms
that worry me about a potential colon
cancer or inflammatory bowel disease
that refuse to get colonoscopies and
want to try things like this as an
at-home remedy years before they seek
out real medical treatment which could
make it too late well i feel that the
350 000 for 10
is right how about 10 for 500 000. i
don't accept that
if you're interested if you really want
a shark
then you would entertain that seriously
actually we're going to take lori's
offer
wow
okay
and the rest is history how much money
did squatty potty make over the last
five years right here on screen probably
way too much the squatty potty
reluctantly i'm in oxygen is the most
essential element for the heart for the
brain and for the muscles to function
we've all seen supplemental oxygen being
utilized by professional football
players on the sidelines aviators
mountaineers and by many other people
for many different purposes usually
those purposes are for altitude purposes
where partial pressures change boost
oxygen is 95 pure aviators breathing
oxygen compressed into affordable and
portable aluminum canisters it's an
all-natural product for health and
wellness yo check this out
mad health and wellness for free our
mission and boost oxygen oh my god it
has flavors yo you ever tried that pink
grapefruit oxygen though
and kevin if we sucked all the oxygen
out of this room we'd all be literally
dead to you right now ah
a buy or fake product so what we're
gonna do we're all gonna try the ox oh
my god there's an oxygen one that is
called the think tank that boosts memory
my memory's about to explode so you take
the mask you put it under the nose and
over the mouth then you press the
trigger one two three
and what do you get from that bro you
breathe all day you you took a little
breath of oxygen it's not like your your
body physically can take in more oxygen
you realize that right like there's a
specific set of oxygen percentage-wise
in the air it stays that way no matter
how high you turn it up and even if you
turn it up momentarily for your little
one second burst that changes nothing
it's a one million dollar capital
investment
for a five percent equity stake and
boost oxygen oh my god
20 million dollar company right there to
sell you air who's using this nobody i
hope when you go up from florida to vail
and you go skiing and you're breathing
hard you see oxygen like i'm gonna try
that you try it and you like it you use
it when you're there when you go back to
florida you don't need it anymore but
we're still going to sell it to you
anyway is this fda approved it's not if
you're not right yet yeah because it's a
bs product if they were regulated by the
fda would get taken off the market in 30
it wouldn't even be let on the market
because they would have to make some
sort of claim to say that it treats
something my concern is
you're trying to educate people on a
problem they don't really know they have
they don't have it bro bring me out of
this show i would flip out you know how
they spill water on each other i would
just spill water on purpose looking at
the five of us none of us took it
and said wow this is a no-brainer yeah
because it doesn't do anything mark my
guy he's selling you a think
air container hit the air container and
then think how stupid it is
pretty sharp little numberonies there
when we're cutting in half i think the
deal's reasonable let's go
we'll take the deal the varshovsky is
heavily out maybe because i didn't have
my think oxygen container so just
imagine you're at a dinner party
or maybe even a tailgate okay better yet
we're at a local bar with some friends
adding some champagne would anyone care
for a glass yes sure
i bet he's not going to give me one i
thought you were joking i mean i got a
little glory sparkly water
before you know it the night's over and
it's time to go home and what are you
gonna say your breath smells the most
important question is are you safe to
drive oh
and who would want to carry one of these
bulky old breathalyzers around well
that's not the only issue the issue is
whether or not you're inebriated you
know you might be under the limit but
you still can be inebriated so that's
why i created
brethrometer the world's first
smartphone breathalyzer interesting let
me show you how it works simply
retract the audio jack
plug it into a smartphone
activate the app
within a matter of seconds you'll be
able to know what your breath alcohol
level is i need to know only one
question and one question only has it
been tested by independent labs and
compared against baseline real-world
breath alcohol content machines you can
even hail a cab with a push of a button
that's called uber so please join or
lift
me on this mission or revolution to help
or curb
people make smarter or one of the many
apps near you basically go ahead and
plug it into the audio jack of your
smartphone um all you need to do is hit
the start button okay
go ahead and breathe into this hole like
there
[Music]
you're at a point zero four right now
that would be legal yeah you're legal
you could technically still get a ticket
for that i'm pretty sure like just
because you're under the legal limit
doesn't mean that you're completely fine
to drive if you're at .04 and still
swerving you could still go to jail i'm
starting to think of this as more of a
multi-function breathalyzer so the next
one we're actually trying to focus on is
diabetes it's in clinical trials and
it's obviously less intrusive yeah but i
don't think that would be nearly as
accurate especially for type 1 diabetics
who have to gauge their blood sugar in
order to decide how much insulin to give
themselves that's a very risky game if
not accurate 500 000 from mark cuban for
15
and 500 000 from the rest of the sharks
we're gonna split it right for a total
of thirty percent for one million
dollars
and the power of shark tank what are you
gonna do
i accept
all
right
[Applause]
the shark arshavsky's out because i
heard zero research here only future
plans for research five minutes later a
little update here because the
breathometer was ordered by the ftc the
federal trade commission in january 2017
to provide refunds for all its devices
sold between 2013 and 2015 because it
frequently understated blood alcohol
levels and the ftc investigators
concluded the company was aware of this
they decided to not inform its customers
despite this fact and continued
marketing and selling its products
this is why you don't take people's word
at face value without evidence in this
day and age
appearance is
everything agreed poor kevin got zoomed
in on what if i told you could look 10
years younger i would buy it without any
plastic surgery or injection i would
spend all my money on it face yoga face
yoga it's a really great natural
solution oh thank god
your youthful appearance we wake up
sleeping muscle in the face i actually
don't mind the idea of face yoga kevin
i'm not mad i can't see your face as
always oh that's not today
oh you look great but if you do face
yoga exercises oh don't make your
clothes it can't look like this no come
on
don't make the claim if you want to
reduce fat anywhere in your body you
cannot spot reduce if i have excess
adipose tissue fat tissue on my arm me
doing curls with this arm will not make
this arm reduce fat content that is a
whole body approach so what she's
recommending here is bs would you like
to come up here so that i can make you
look 10 years younger yeah sure some
exercises together okay i don't mind the
face yogurts the claims i have a problem
with let's lift up the corners of the
mouth a little bit higher smile
and then stick out your tongue
[Music]
[Music]
the noises thank god bear's not in this
room he would have a panic attack
there's no easy way to say this but
it's just not a fit for me
i thought he was gonna ask her if she's
had work done i'm out coco okay thank
you i will be laughing at them when i
become very very successful
and if they come to me at that time oh
coco please teach me some exercise no i
will not teach them any exercise you
already taught him though please leave
with your saggy face oh
she hit him with the t
i am very much out
stratsky
i'm in the business of keeping boobs
high and dry
that's right boob sweat i know it
doesn't sound very attractive and trust
me it does not feel very attractive
either but it is something that's very
real for so many women in my patients
who have larger breasts they do have
higher rates of fungal yeast canadal
infections underneath the breast
actually sometimes it's misdiagnosed as
a yeast infection and it can actually be
a full-blown cellulitis which means a
bacterial infection so i came up with a
solution of my own the tata towel
that's right
it's a towel for your tatas okay oh my
goodness i mean if that helps you
especially like if you're doing your
hair and you're blasting the hairdryer
and it's hot in there i could see
wearing that to decrease the amount of
sweat i thought you might want to feel
how it really feels
i really don't need one of the reasons
but you know what they make great gifts
i could see this work somebody's wearing
it i need the help like you said i've
made a lot of mistakes what are you
gonna do
i'll take it i'm gonna i'm gonna take
her off her
yay the shark of arshovsky is in and i
would make the best tick tock dances
wearing those click here to find out the
part of your body you should never shave
maybe not never but definitely click it
and as always stay happy and healthy